[Musik]
sabine erreicht deutschland und die bahn
reagiert wegen des sturmtiefs soll der
fernverkehr bundesweit eingestellt
werden
raus aus dem virus gebiet weitere 20
deutsche sind zurück aus buchen und
jetzt in berlin in quarantäne bittere
saison aus in garmisch nach ihrem
beeindruckenden heimsieg gestern stürzt
viktoria rebensburg heute beim super g
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster willkommen beim
sonntäglichen nachrichtenüberblick mit
kurzem sport und norbert könig und gerne
schön und wir beginnen mit sabine dem
orkantief das zurzeit deutschland
unsicher macht so unsicher dass die bahn
den fernverkehr bundesweit und
zusätzlich den regionalverkehr in
nordrhein-westfalen einstellt auch
etliche flüge fallen aus
im norden deutschlands gibt es schäden
und probleme auf schienen und straßen
das schlimmste allerdings soll in den
nächsten stunden erst noch kommen anselm
stern berichtet sabine ist da der winter
sturm wirbelt kräftig er bringt heftige
orkanböen lebensgefährlich auf dem
brocken gefährlich auch im flachland
beendet werden viele reisepläne
die bahn reagiert drastisch nach und
nach soll der fernverkehr in ganz
deutschland eingestellt werden wir haben
uns dazu entschieden weil wir aus den
früheren stürmen auch gelernt haben
das ist besser ist züge in kritische
region gar nicht erst mal hinein fahren
zu lassen wir können uns um fahrgäste
viel besser in den bahnhöfen kümmern was
wir vermeiden wollen ist dass züge auf
freier strecke stehen bleiben
doch was vermieden werden soll passiert
in emsland kraft am späten nachmittag
dieser zug gegen einen umgestürzten baum
verletzt wird offenbar niemand doch
weiter geht es hier nicht wie für so
viele reisende im ganzen land wir fahren
jetzt wieder im bus nach hause um dann
im auto weiter zu fahren weil wir sonst
heute nacht nicht nach hause kommen
dabei aber ist vorsicht angesagt denn
der sturm ist stark und wird wohl noch
stärker
wir sollten dieses orkantief sehr ernst
nehmen es ist eine lebensgefährliche
lage eine kaltfront über zieht dabei von
nordwest richtung südost ganz
deutschland und dabei können orkanböen
ausgelöst werden vor allem in der nähe
von gewittern um 130 kilometer pro
stunde
pendeln reisen verdammt schwierig auch
viele flieger müssen am boden bleiben
der sturm sorgt wohl nur bei manchen
schulkindern für gute laune in nordrhein
westfalen fällt in mehreren städten der
unterricht aus der weg durch den sturm
wäre zu gefährlich
dazu jetzt glas thomsen auf sylt wo der
sturm war schon heftig wütet class wie
sieht's aus auf der insel
[Musik]
ja ich stehe hier in listen ort ist
norddeutschlands den ganzen tag
überhaupt der sturm zugenommen hat in
dieser intensität jetzt geht damit der
kran stärker über die insel in den
kommenden stunden morgen eigentlich ja
so ein bisschen sich abschwächen der
stürmer war eine entwarnung für die
insel kann es nicht geben denn der sand
der der insel schützen soll am
weststrand der den sommer über
aufgeschüttet wurde ist an vielen orten
komplett weg und dort liegt insel
schutzlos dem strom ausgeliefert oliver
deuker sie sind am bahnhof in hannover
das sind ja drastische maßnahmen dass
die bahn alle fernzüge stehen lässt ja
das stimmt und das zeigt der
auswirkungen hier am bahnhof in hannover
sehen sind etliche leute festgesetzt
kommen nicht weiter oder auch für morgen
wird was den berufsverkehr anbelangt
wird es mit erheblichen problemen mit
erheblichen problemen zu rechnen sein
die züge werden weiter ausfall der sturm
ist morgen früh noch nicht vorbei viele
menschen die wir im zug nicht
weiterkommen wenn versuchen das auto zu
nutzen auf straßen die ohnehin voll sind
auf straßen wo vielleicht wir
runtergekommen sind also ein absolutes
chaos werden gefragt morgen geduld und
vorsicht
danke nach hannover und nach sylt wir
halten sie natürlich weiterhin auf dem
laufenden auf heute.de haben wir einen
live blog
nach der gescheiterten
ministerpräsidenten wahl in thüringen
werden nun die scherben zusammengekehrt
in berlin nutzten spd und fdp dafür
jeweils ihre schon länger geplante
klausur mit viel selbstkritik die fdp
deren parteichef einräumt der afg in
erfurt in die falle gegangen zu sein
die spd sieht sich dagegen als
standhafte bollwerk gegen rechts daniel
pontzen es ist eine für die spd zuletzt
eher ungewohnte rolle als hort der
stabilität als ordnende kraft als dieses
nach dem thüringer tobago präsentiert
ich glaube dass die spd mit ihrem
verhalten seit der wahl von herrn
kemmerich zum ministerpräsidenten von
thüringen mit den stimmen der afd sehr
deutlich gemacht hat dass es bei uns
kein wackeln gibt dass die spd seit eh
und je das bollwerk gegen rechts in
deutschland ist ohne thüringen wäre der
fokus auch auf die konkurrierenden
parteiinternen kraftzentren gefallen
so nutzt man die chance für ein signal
der geschlossenheit mit blick auf die
anderen als das ganz klar
sowohl die cdu als auch die fdp haben
eine lange runde innerparteiliche
debatten vor sich es müssen klarstellung
vorgenommen werden die auch überall in
deutschland von allen akzeptiert werden
die fdp setzte diese debatte heute fort
erkennbares ziel die folgen dieser woche
abzumildern in der er seine partei auch
als opfer sieht hfd hat eine neue
strategie der konstruktiv destruktiven
oppositionsarbeit die fdp ist jetzt nun
zum ersten mal diesen taktischen
manövern als erste partei die falle
gegangen dass thüringen thema bleiben
könnte darauf deutet unterdessen die
empfehlung von alexander gauland die afg
solle dort nun für bodo ramelow als
ministerpräsident stimmen bei der das
amt dann auch nicht annehmen dürfe die
lage bleibt partei strategisch äußerst
diffizil zum corona virus 813 menschen
sind bereits daran gestorben mehr als
bei der sars pandemie vor 17 jahren aus
der besonders betroffenen stadt wuchern
in china sind jetzt weitere 20 menschen
nach deutschland zurückgekehrt
hans-jürgen mit der scorte in die
quarantäne
bereits am mittag waren die 20
rückkehrer in berlin
in diesem regierungsflugzeug gelandet
hier im drk klinikum köpenick sollen sie
jetzt zwei wochen in einem isolierten
bereich von fachkräften beobachtet
werden und vor allem wird der amtsarzt
sie in empfang nehmen die abstriche
machen damit wir schnell wie möglich
auch die tests durchführen können hier
haben wir das große glück in berlin mit
der charité das hier
die tests durchgeführt werden wir
rechnen morgen mit den ergebnissen erst
gestern war auf dem klinikgelände im
berliner südosten ein verwaltungsgebäude
für die unterbringung der neuankömmlinge
vorbereitet worden
streng getrennt vom übrigen krankenhaus
sowie bereits 126 china rückkehrer in
einer kaserne im rheinland-pfälzischen
germersheim die am letzten wochenende
aus china zurück geholt wurden sollen
sie hier so lange und der amtsärztliche
aufsicht verbringen bis die
ansteckungsgefahr vorbei ist die
klinikleitung sieht keine gefahr für
patienten oder mitarbeiter
das krankenhaus ist komplett von diesem
bereich abgetrennt sowohl räumlich als
auch personell
ob tatsächlich jemand mit dem corona
virus infiziert ist wollen die berliner
behörden morgen bekanntgeben
nach einem amoklauf im nordosten
thailands haben einsatzkräfte den
mutmaßlichen täter erschossen
der 32 jährige soldat hatte 26 menschen
getötet 57 weitere verletzt
der angriff begann gestern in einer
kaserne dort erschoss der mann zunächst
drei menschen
anschließend so die polizei habe er
waffen und munition gestohlen und den
amoklauf in einem einkaufszentrum
fortgesetzt
zum sport und zu laut und tischtennis
mit einem deutschen doppelerfolg beim
europa top 16 turnier petrissa solja
verteidigt ihren titel erfolgreich und
rekord europameister timo boll gewinnt
das turnier schon zum siebten mal der
triumph in montreux ein besonderer
damit stellt ball den rekord von
schwedens tischtennis ikone jan ove
waldner 1 im finale gegen den slowenen
darkorbit zeigt sich der düsseldorfer in
starker verfassung und beweist 18 jahre
nach seinem ersten titelgewinn immer
noch ein feines händchen nur den ersten
durchgang muss ball abgeben danach
dominiert der das duell der matchball
nach 36 minuten 4 zu 1 nach sätzen der
sieg auch in dieser höhe verdient
im dfb pokal stehen die viertelfinal
paarungen fest viertligist fc
saarbrücken freut sich auf fortuna
düsseldorf die bundesliga duelle anfang
märz lauten schalke gegen die bayern
frankfurt gegen bremen und leverkusen
gegen union berlin
triumph und schmerz im alpinen rennsport
für viktoria rebensburg ist die saison
nach einem sturz in garmisch
partenkirchen zu ende
alexander schmid dagegen schafft sein
bestes weltcup ergebnis
für ihn ist es der erste podestplatz
alexander schmid in chamonix-mont-blanc
gewinnt der allgäuer sein rennen und
platz drei im parallel-riesenslalom
gegen die us amerikaner tommy ford
stefan luitz um die nuss strasser
dagegen schieden früh aus saison-aus für
viktoria rebensburg einen tag nach ihrem
abfahrts triumph gestern folgt ein
schmerzhafter sturz im super-g ein
lockeres ab schwingendes ziel ist danach
zwar noch möglich
nach eingehender untersuchung und
festgestellte verletzung im linken knie
aber muss rebensburg sechs bis acht
wochen pausieren und die
bundesliga-partie gladbach gegen köln
ist wegen des sturms abgesagt worden
damit sind wir zurück beim stürmischen
wetter in den nächsten stunden ist vor
allem die mitte betroffen morgen früh
aber auch der süden mit orkanböen regen
und gewittern morgen stürmt das auch
noch den ganzen tag über in den
mittelgebirgen schnee bis runter auf 600
meter 7 bis 15 grad so viel in kürze von
uns danke für ihr interesse und bleiben
sie wenn irgend möglich zu hause muss
bis morgen hier geht es jetzt weiter mit
berlin und gunther love energy